Freunde ich bin gerade in Hamburg für
eine Kooperation und habe ein bisschen
Zeit auf dem Hotelzimmer deshalb was
mache ich natürlich bestelle ich bei dem
besten Restaurants der Stadt ihr kennt
es mittlerweile leute das ist immer eine
gute Idee einfach beim besten bestellen
dann kriegt man schon was gutes wir
machen das wie in Berlin letztes Mal das
heißt wir werden bei Volt bei ubaids und
bei Lieferando beim besten Restaurant
bestellt zumindest beim bestbewerteten
wie gut ist dann ist werden wir sehen
gucken wir mal was es so gibt ich habe
die erste liefer App geöffnet schauen
wir mal gemeinsam rein wir gehen ganz
klassisch auf Restaurants durchs Burger
da habe ich ja bei den Hamburg
Fußballplatz schon gegessen der ist sehr
krass ist sie nur mit 8,00
repräsentativ dafür wie guten Laden
wirklich ist und manchmal sind auch die
bestbewerteten ein bisschen eigenartig
aber wir schauen einfach mal wir Filtern
Bewertung zack Platz 1 Pokers bubbley
irgendwie habe ich nie Glück es kommt
nie einfach so ein geisteskrankes
Restaurant auf Platz 1 da gibt's auch
nur Bubble Tea gucken wir mal auf Platz
2 promibile als Donuts normalerweise
würde ich sagen bei einem Donuts an
überhaupt keinen Bock aber ich ganz viel
von gehört dem geben wir mal eine Chance
ganze würde ich sagen und im Prinzip ich
sag mal so wir bestellen bei drei Läden
das heißt wir kriegen vielleicht jetzt
ein bisher so auch okay mendrin
Cheesecake gib ihm zur Bestellung
hinzufügen 3,90 € nicht wenig für ein
Donut man kann auch einfach die 12er Box
für 36 Euro nehmen classic Donut muss
man auch mal testen findet sugar Boston
cream Bienenstich apple pie und das
war's auch schon okay krass ich glaube
wir müssen vier bestellen wenn du ein
Cheesecakes cinemanager Franke sorted
ich würde sagen wir wechseln die liefert
ich bestelle das ganze und wir gucken
was es sonst noch so gut es gibt alles
klar nächster Adresse heißt über eats
und wir gucken einfach mal was das hier
Leckeres gibt wir gehen hier oben ins
Menü gehen auf Bewertung und lassen
einmal ausspucken was die bestbewerteten
Restaurants sind Platz 1 ist Q Reto
lange Reihe keine Ahnung was lange Reihe
ist curito klingt für mich wie Burrito
und damit mexikanisch das wäre lustig
weil in Berlin hatten wir auf jeden Fall
ja auch ein burritoladen ich gehe mal
drauf 4,9 Sterne aus über 100 Bewertung
ich habe in Berlin Video schon erzählt
ich vermisse Bayar Burrito in Köln und
vielleicht komme ich hier auf meine
Kosten also auf jeden Fall alle
möglichen Variationen haben sie noch was
anderes Quesadillas das heißt ich werde
mir wahrscheinlich ein Brito bestellen
wir gucken mal was das für einen gibt
aber irgendwie hat mich dieser caliente
angesprochen weil ich glaube das heißt
scharf alright geht richtig schnell hier
Leute auch das sieht gut aus ich würde
sagen wir bestellen hier und wechseln
zur letzten liefer-app zu Lieferando um
wirklich entscheiden zu können was das
beste lieferessen in Hamburg war und wir
bestellen beim letzten Restaurant Leute
Ich sage euch so viel danach bin ich
wahrscheinlich wieder komplett
pickelpacke voll und kann mich hier
durch Hamburg rollen wir haben 449
Restaurants die größte Auswahl bisher
und 4,5 ist wahrscheinlich aber nicht
das beste erstmal filtern wir aber
wieder nach Bewertung fünf Sterne sieben
Ergebnisse Räume Mops aber hier haben
Angebot laufe ich weiß nicht ob die
deshalb jetzt nicht gesponsert okay
deshalb sind die auf Platz 1 immer
allerdings 879 Bewertung CHIO Sushi Bar
hat nur 11 dann das andere sechs dann
wieder 60 deshalb ist dieses Rollmops
Ding mit fünf Sternen eigentlich die
verdiente Nummer eins würde ich sagen
bei fünf Sterne aus 879 Bewertung das
steht natürlich für den Laden so
irgendwie eine redekombination heute
Donuts Burrito Sophie
Vertrags mit Hamachi so wie sing mir das
Lied vom Tod wahrscheinlich irgendwie
aber 16 Euro 49 bestellen wir einfach
mal gucken wir was kommt ich bin
wirklich sehr gespannt wir machen das
hier im Dienste der Wissenschaft boah
das ist schon echt relativ teuer aber
ich meine die Qualität wird dann
wahrscheinlich überzeugen ich meine das
Go von Steffen Henssler ist ja auch
relativ teuer aber dafür hat übelst geil
die Rollen sind wirklich grün lila gelb
orange also eingefärbt wird sagen wir
machen dieses Rollen mir den Lachs bei
zwei Sachen sind wir schon bei 33 €
Bento Boxen kann man sich auch machen
entweder das Ende vom Regenbogen vegan
Sonnenlicht trifft Regentropfen vegan
oder vegan finde ich blöd dann hat man
chicken Roll beef Roll und als mögliche
das klingt irgendwie geil Granatapfel
träumchen das nehmen wir noch mit rein
dann sind wir auch schon bei
46,96 €. ich bestelle das ganze und
jetzt gleich sollte auch schon die erste
Bestellung ankommen deshalb weiter
geht's euch muss es auch schon
aufgefallen sein im Prinzip wird gerade
alles teurer ob es im Supermarkt beim
Einkaufen ist egal wo deshalb bin ich
froh dass man heutiger Partner eine
kleine Lösung für das Problem bereithält
schauen wir mal nach was drin ist
motatoes hat es sich zur Aufgabe gemacht
Lebensmittel zu retten um sie günstig an
euch weiterzugeben es ist quasi
günstiger für euch und gleichzeitig
nachhaltig die Produkte sind bis zu 80%
günstiger durch das stetig wechselnde
Sortiment habt ihr immer ein neues
Einkaufserlebnis in meinem Paket sind
Kuchen Nudeln Getränke Reis also
wirklich eine große große Vielfalt an
Dingen ihr seht also das ist ein sehr
üppiger Einkauf der so einen 39,27 €
gekostet hat in meiner mottatos Box wenn
ich das Ganze im Supermarkt im
Einzelhandel gekauft hätte hätte ich
fast 15 € mehr dafür bezahlt ihr könnt
euch vielleicht denken warum z.B dieser
Punsch hier in der Box gelandet ist das
ist einfach so Saison Ware also
winterpunsch ohne Alkohol den man
natürlich auch außerhalb der Winterzeit
trinken kann und es wäre um ehrlich zu
sein einfach schade wenn der im Müll
landen würde nur weil einfach kein
Winter mehr ist deshalb vielleicht
einfach mal so einen schönen
Frühlingsabend mit einer heißen Tasse
Punsch genießen oder ihn einfach kalt
trinken
es geht nicht mal er muss warm sein
falls ihr euch fragt warum die Produkte
so günstig angeboten werden können es
können kleine verpackungsfehler sein es
kann verkürztes Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum
sein verschiedene kleine Dinge die am
Geschmack und an der Qualität rein gar
nichts verändern die handelt sich also
nicht um minderwertige Produkte aber
Produkte die ihr trotzdem günstiger
kaufen könnt der Einkauf von zu teuren
Lebensmitteln ist also Geschichte alles
davon habe ich selbst ausgewählt also
ich habe nicht einfach eine
Überraschungsbox bekommen deshalb Check
not haters ab deren Motto ist wir retten
damit Du Spaß aber ich habe natürlich
noch was für euch wir können mit meinem
Code max 15 nur in den nächsten 48
Stunden 15 % auf eure Bestellung sparen
weiter geht's mit dem Video okay Leute
die erste Bestellung ist angekommen
brahmi bei stones in der Reihenfolge
Videos bestellt haben ohne Tüte an oder
einfach so überreicht ja vegane Donuts
deshalb bin ich auch gespannt so wie die
beiden die sich ne schauen wir mal
gemeinsam rein
[Musik]
okay sieht wirklich sehr gut aus und es
riecht noch viel besser also wirklich so
so ein butträger süßer Geruch hier in
der Luft ich würde sagen wir probieren
als erstes mal den klaren Klassiker der
chocolate sprinkle Donut ich gehe
einfach mal rein ich freue mich auf das
als erstes bekannt war oder Royal Donuts
also das ist eigentlich ein bisschen
sympathischer dass man nicht sowieso
Maxi King kinderbrunnen überall drauf
hat sondern so geile Kreation macht ja
ist dieser Donut wirklich
außergewöhnlich ich finde es schmeckt
erstmal nicht vegan ich weiß nicht ob
das normalerweise immer vegan sind aber
der schmeckt auf jeden Fall so absolut
vollwertig so ne dunkle Schokolade klar
die sprinkel sind auch so ganz geil ist
jetzt noch nicht glaube ich dass weshalb
die bekannt geworden sind wie gesagt ein
geiler Donut aber nichts verrücktes die
Kreation mit Apfel Zimt
[Musik]
ist halt ein guter Donut ne aber auch
das hier ist halt wieder ein Klassiker
deshalb gucken wir mal nach saltat
Caramel ihr merkt schon Leute heute habe
ich rein auf jeden Fall so mit
karamellstückchen oben drauf dieser sehr
sehr dicken Glasur der schmeckt so
sockig fettig man spürt wirklich so
diesen kristallinen Zucker teilweise
noch so zwischen den Zähnen ich finde
das ist etwas was ein Donut machen muss
man muss sich danach schlechter fühlen
als davor und das muss lecker sein und
auch der letzte ist mit Sicherheit nicht
von schlechten Eltern der Special Donut
hat Mandarin Cheesecake Donut ich weiß
nicht was es ist irgendwas für dich
haben geil nicht nur an dem donnert der
ist wirklich sehr lecker aber auch an
dem Konzept wiegen Donuts damit kann man
sich so selbst so ein bisschen vormachen
dass man was gesund ist irgendwie oder
sowas passiert ist dabei haut man sich
einfach ehrenlos Donuts rein
kann auf jeden Fall etwas ich bin acht
von zehn geben nicht falsch verstehen
ist auf jeden Fall krass
eigentlich auch alles richtig gemacht
ich habe zwar irgendwas falsch
verstanden als allererstes den Nachtisch
gegessen aber ich würde sagen wir machen
weiter mit der nächsten Bestellung und
hier ist es vor mir hier oben drauf
haben wir einen kleinen Container
bekommen mit unserem Granatapfel Cashew
Dessert sehr spannend das werden wir uns
fürs Ende aufbewahren jetzt gucken wir
mal in den Karton hinein grundsätzlich
erstmal alles was wir hier geliefert
bekommen ist fancy im Kartons eingepackt
Hamburg liefern könnt ihr auf jeden Fall
schon mal aber könnt ihr auch kochen ich
muss schon sagen die Donnerstag
eigentlich echt gut ich bin einfach
nicht so die nachtkatze der letzte der
war schon so eine neuneinhalb von 10 in
der menory Cheesecake aber jetzt sind
wir bei Sushi gucken wir uns mal das
Sushi an
[Musik]
es sieht wirklich nicht verkehrt aus
aber es hat auch 50 € gekostet jetzt
muss es extrem gut schmecken finde ich
damit das gerecht fertig ist das
lieferkonzept ist super ne in dieser Box
das bleibt alles in Ordnung und stelle
die Sojasoße kommt in einer kleinen
Flasche daher einer Glasflasche auf dem
Furz ich habe gerade noch mal
nachgeschaut weil der Reis nicht bunt in
den einzelnen Gerichten das wirkt so als
wäre das einfach so ein bisschen schnell
schnell gearbeitet und das wäre
natürlich jetzt nicht so toll wenn man
50 Euro dafür bezahlt wir starten mit
einem basic und zwar mit Lachs Avocado
Maki auch eine relativ große Rolle für
Maki würde ich sagen und ich probiere
Top Quali also Fisch ist super Avocado
schön cremig der Reis hat ein bisschen
bis so wie es sein soll Trüffel Mario
auf lachsmaki und jetzt kommen wir zu
den Lachs Tatar es ist schon geil und
das hier macht bestimmt auch ordentlich
satt das hat ja auch 16 € gekostet ne
zwei Stück davon deshalb sollte es auch
satt machen aber ich probiere mal boah
geil mariniert leichte Schärfe der
Thunfisch ist wirklich so super super
weich aber nichtsdestotrotz mehr
persönlich fehlt so der krasse Flash
weil das kenne ich halt von z.B go bei
Steffen Henssler das hat aber allerdings
wirklich halt fünf Sterne aus über 800
Bewertungen probieren wir noch mal die
Special Roll schmeckt fresh 100 % super
Zutaten also sehr gutes Sushi top
Zutaten aber der Preis schafft noch
höhere Erwartung geht ja noch mal zurück
schaut euch das Video an wo ich zum
Beispiel bei Steffen Henssler oder
Gaumen gut bestellt habe das einfach nur
noch eine Ecke krasser irgendwie so von
den Kreation her ich hoffe das ein
bisschen Klarheit rein weil ich finde
das beim besten Willen nicht schlecht
beinahe hätte ich unser Dessert
vergessen Granatapfel Cashews und
Meersalz der Name ist das Rezept aber
auf jeden Fall eine geile Alternative zu
irgendein paar süßen Dessert Props dafür
ein bisschen Platz habe ich noch im
Bauch Brummis auch hungrig ich würde
sagen wir verdrücken das hier und dann
kümmern wir uns um den Burrito und
bestellen Nummer 3 ist angekommen boah
alter Schwede ist das ein aperolo nimm
doch bitte in die Hand
oh ja du bist gerade nach vorne
das ist ein familienurito wir reden ja
auch von 14,50 €. das ist ein Apparat
Alter ich wünsche dir eine Waage dabei
das beste Restaurant über eats ein ganz
Hamburg über 100 Bewertung 4,9 Sterne
das bekommt man oh das riecht richtig
was wir jetzt durch kommt also erstmal
15 € für so eine Portion ist schon
wieder okay ist halt eigentlich wirklich
ein zwei Personen denken beef caliente
Burrito boah
der ist so soft innen drin ich finde man
merkt dass wenn man hier so einmal
zusammendrückt guck mal der Anschnitt
sieht auch schon super aus also diese
mango-salzer das Beef ist geil gewürzt
boah der kommt richtig krass
eine gewisse Schärfe bringt er doch mit
aber das ist wirklich ein Brett Alter so
gut wie der in Köln das ist die richtige
Frage liebe ich ihn so sehr wie Bay Area
ich liebe ihn schon sehr es ist für mich
glaube ich auch der Tages Sieger wird
bei 4,9 auf jeden Fall mitgehen
vielleicht sogar 55 also curito ist auf
jeden Fall ein Win würde ich sagen also
Leute mach mal wieder Hamburg hat sehr
leckere Dinge zu liefern komplett aus
den Socken gehauen wollte ich nicht aber
es ist ja auch immer zusammen Spiel
bestimmt ist unter den anderen
Restaurants eben nicht mit der besten
Bewertung eins wo ich mir sagen krank
das will ich unbedingt auch in Köln
haben aber dann wird bei der Lieferung
so oft reingekackt oder irgendwelche
anderen Faktoren haben dafür gesorgt
dass es halt eben nicht das beste
bewertete Restaurant ist zum Beispiel
durch Burger ist halt auch übelst geil
gewesen und hatte nur acht von zehn ihr
versteht auch nicht was ich meine Leute
vielen Dank fürs zusehen ich hoffe ich
konnte euch unterhalten wir sehen uns
beim nächsten Video wieder macht's gut
und bis dahin ciao ciao